welcome to the daily climate show coming
up
a warning of famine in the horn of
africa as drought and food insecurity
combined with deadly consequences
dozens killed millions stranded as the
worst monsoon rains in years hit
bangladesh and northern india
and a new president for colombia on a
mission to address climate change
[Music]
hello and welcome to the daily climate
show where we report on the impact of
climate change hear from those most
affected and track the changes that are
responsible for those impacts on the
planet and we start today with a warning
of a humanitarian disaster in eastern
africa due to both drought and the
impact of the war in ukraine now the
horn of africa is facing severe drought
after the rainy season fouled for the
fourth year in a row
with somalia and the self-declared
republic of somaliland facing the worst
drought in 40 years almost 800 000
people have left their homes in the
countryside to seek help in cities
combined with international food
shortages caused by the war in ukraine
which is a huge full food exporter the
foul rainy season and a lack of aid
funding have created the perfect storm
that could quickly lead to famine
and more than seven
million people are facing high levels of
food insecurity in the coming months
plus
one and a half million children under
the age of five are facing acute
malnutrition
well our international affairs editor
dominic wagon reports from mandera in
the self-declared republic of somaliland
and a warning his report begins with
images of mount and irish children
receiving treatment which viewers may
find distressing
[Music]
two-month-old muhammad is lucky to be
alive
born eight weeks premature in a village
all but wiped out by drought
deca his 17 year old mother traveled 400
miles to get him to hospital and didn't
think he'd make it
she was very very upset and worried
about her condition first time she came
she was worried like
he will die
he still looks desperately ill but
doctors say he should survive
many like him haven't
the ward is full they're putting
patience now on the floor
one-year-old mohammed has been given a
nasal tube to feed him urgently needed
fluids
ward dr abdul rahman says he's afraid of
what could be on the way
the rains are not come early the city
will come once day by day and the number
of bridges that will be increasing even
hour by hour day by day and we cannot
handle it or we cannot save them
right across the horn of africa they are
bracing themselves for the double impact
of war and famine
the worst drought in 40 years is
combining with the effects of russia's
invasion of ukraine the ball there may
be thousands of miles away from these
markets but it's pushing up the prices
of grain and fuel to unprecedented
levels making the impact of the drought
even worse
[Music]
the drought now threatens the worst
famine for years camps are already
filling
with people who've lost any means of
supporting their families
the parents are desperate
[Music]
like sofia a few months ago well off by
her standards she's now destitute she's
had to move to the camp after the
drought killed all her livestock
my grandfather was a goat herd my father
was a goat herd
i grew up in that life and ended up with
500 goats and four camels and they've
all been wiped out i've got nothing now
[Music]
the rains have failed for a fourth year
with no grass left for the goats they
pull leaves from trees to eat
but getting food to the people who need
it will be a huge challenge
across the region millions are facing
acute hunger in the worst drought in
over a generation compounded by the war
in ukraine and without massive
international help agencies say hundreds
of thousands will die of starvation
dominic waghorn sky news mandera
somaliland
well let's get a bit more of today's
climate news now firefighters in spain
are struggling to contain wildfires
after an unusually early heat waves saw
temperatures reach over 40 degrees down
the northwestern province of samora is
among the worst hit areas more than 61
000 acres of forest were destroyed in
the area and hundreds of people
evacuated the biodiversity hot spots is
home to one of the largest wolf
populations in western europe
now china has also been experiencing a
heat wave with power consumption surging
in some areas now the warmer
temperatures mean homes and businesses
are demanding more power as they switch
on air conditioning to try to stay cool
now the province of henan home to a
hundred million people set a new record
yesterday using over 65 million
kilowatts that's according to state
media longer hotter summers caused by
climate change could force china to
ration power consumption during these
periods
colombia has elected gustavo petro as
its first left-wing president the former
guerrilla fighter has vowed to end oil
exploration it's controversial in
colombia as it's a major source of
exports earnings francia marquez a
long-time environmental activist will
become the country's first black female
vice president
the lawyer was forced to flee her home
after receiving death threats for
opposing illegal gold mining in her area
now more than 60 people have died in
flooding across india and bangladesh
with millions of homes underwater now
both countries have called in the
military to help rescue those stranded
the flooding in bangladesh has been
described by government officials as
potentially the country's worst since
2004.
now the extreme monsoon rains have hit
large parts of northern bangladesh and
northeastern india and it follows just
weeks after pre-monsoon flash floods
from india's north eastern states and
that had a huge impact on bangladesh
well joining us now is dr saiful islam
he's director of the institute of water
and flood management at bangladesh
university of engineering and technology
thanks so much for joining me dr islam
so first of all we know that bangladesh
is prone to flooding and monsoon rain of
course but how do you think climate
change has impacted the situation
we have uh seen
devastating uh flood uh recent uh
times and particularly this year we have
seen huge amount of rainfall occur in
the episteme catchment particularly
north east bangladesh and
the flood in the past we have seen
bangladesh is known for flood but this
time the amount of water come and it
stays within very short time
and many cities in the northeast
countries not this part of the country
has been underwater for several days and
we feel like the pattern of
flooding is changing
successive floods and every year we find
floods and now other part of the country
as you mentioned the north and north
central also affected so
these are the signals that
weather pattern has changed it becomes
more frequent and intense that has been
mentioned in the last ipcc report sixth
assessment and i was a contributor to
the report as lead author so
things are changing and it's become more
[Music]
vulnerable country become more
vulnerable and we know dr islam that
bangladesh has had huge success in
mitigating climate change but how
prepared do you think flood preparation
is in the country
actually uh as i mentioned that we have
a role model for
managing uh different disaster
particularly flood and cyclone but this
time government is also big challenge
because
everywhere 90 percent of the city is
under water which has not been in the
case in the past so uh even the airport
is under water the power station
the hospitals houses everything is under
water so even rescue relief or operation
on uh particular districts is very
difficult and we are not that much
prepared actually and we have to think
how can manage in the future what needs
to be done as a priority as the uh
recent time and also the long-term plans
okay dr islam thank you very much uh for
talking to us uh today
and some good news now to end on because
bottlenose dolphins are now frequent
visitors to the harbours of new york and
new jersey a new study found the marine
animals return for food and socialising
which could show an improvement in
coastal water quality
well that's all from us today thanks for
watching bye for now
[Music]
you